- New Age conservatism
is classic,
in my, just from looking
at all the people
who identify that way now.
So that's where
I've always been.
And the Democrats,
progressives, liberals,
whatever you wanna
call them on that side,
it's just the most
toxic behavior I've seen
from a group of
people in a long time.
I haven't even seen, I've
never met a religious person
that was far right, that
treated me that way,
the way the people
on the left do.
(dramatic music)
- Hey, I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a former lefty, turned
conservative, a YouTube creator
and a card-carrying lesbian,
here to talk about what's goin'
on with the gay community.
Arielle Scarcella, welcome
to the "Rubin Report."
- Thanks. It's
been long overdue.
- It has been long overdue.
- You said this
started taping, but
like girl, (laughs)
everyone says that I'm
the female Dave Rubin.
And at first I was like, do
they mean that in a bad way?
And some of them do, but
I know it's a good thing,
even though they might
think it's a bad thing.
So either way, I'm flattered,
no matter how they mean it,
I'm flattered either way
- Much obliged, and
I'm glad you're here.
And we are putting
this interview out
during Pride Month.
The gays get a whole month.
I introed you as a
card-carrying lesbian.
Is it true that
lesbians have a card?
Do you have some sort
of laminated card?
- I mean, I think
it's more that,
now we have to have a card,
because now we can't even
define the damn word.
(Dave laughs)
Right? (laughs)
Nobody even knows how
to define a woman.
We can't define lesbian.
So I feel like we
need to have a card
that says this is what
a lesbian means to me.
This is the card.
This is what I am.
And this is what I want.
Kind of like the gay hanky
code back in the seventies,
you know, when they
had the hanky code.
The older gay get
that reference, right.
- The older gays get that.
I get the reference,
but it's a little
bit before my time.
But I wanted to have
you on for awhile,
because you are, when
people say that you're the,
you're the girl Dave Rubin,
or something to that effect,
you left the left
and you survived.
So could we just do
like a two-minute recap?
'Cause it's pretty
recent for you.
It's only in the
last couple of years
you were a left, and ya woke up.
- That's exactly what happened.
I think looking back
now, the past four years,
you know, of my content making,
'cause I'm an OG YouTuber.
I've been making
videos since 2009,
before YouTube was
even a career option.
- Yeah, that's before me.
That years before me.
- Exactly, we were just
online havin' fun, bein' kids.
I was like 23 at the
time, 24, and now,
ya know, looking back,
my entire outlook
on the community has changed.
Back then, it was,
everybody was humble.
Everyone got along.
There was like some
drama here and there,
but usually it had to do
with who was dating who
and who broke up
with who. (laughs)
Not with how someone identified,
or who wants to sleep with who.
And the last five years,
I noticed a huge change
in the YouTube community,
especially the gay community,
the LGBT community on YouTube.
It became volatile,
volatile, whatever the,
I don't know how to
pronounce the word,
'cause I'm from
New York. (laughs)
- I'll accept either one.
You're a Brooklyn girl.
- But you know, it became
just toxic honestly.
And it started, I
would say it started,
with the trans community,
and then it filtered
into the bisexual,
non-binary, queer, whatever,
anything other than
lesbian community.
And then, now it's
starting to filter down
into the gays and lesbians.
And it started to hit me
when I started making
content about trans people
with trans people, by the way.
Trans people were in the videos.
But I got sick of feeling like
everyone was attacking me
for simply having a
different opinion.
And it wasn't,
to me, in my opinion,
it wasn't even
a non-mainstream of opinion.
That's the weird part, right?
This is pretty, it's based on
logic and science. (laughs)
- Yeah, what was your
highly-controversial opinion
on the trans issue?
- Oh, my God.
There's so many
highly-controversial,
transphobic opinions
that I have.
But one of them is, I don't
think somebody is a lesbian,
you know, if they
wanna suck a dick.
Suck a dick, can I
say that on your show?
- You can.
(Arielle laughing)
I think it's the first
time it's been said,
but, uh, ya know.
- It's definitely
the first time.
But like, that's
not controversial.
It shouldn't be controversial.
And somehow yet it is.
I think socially, it
makes a lot of sense when,
there are trans women
who present as women.
Like, you know, my
friend, Blair white,
like my friend, Ashley.
Socially, there'll
always be women,
because they no longer
live their lives as men.
And I have, you know, I've
had that opinion for years.
And I started speaking
out, you know,
about that kind of stuff,
'cause people don't
realize that you can be,
the two things can
be true at once.
You can be pro-trans' rights,
but also pro-women's rights.
And unfortunately there's a line
that's being crossed into
women's rights territory.
And that's when I started
really seeing the divide
with me and the left.
And I was gonna stand by
my morals no matter what,
'cause I'm a New York Italian.
And I finally made a video,
actually connected
with Tim Poole,
who's been a friend
of mine way before
he got big on YouTube.
I connected with him and
I went over his house,
and I was like,
I'm, I need help.
I don't know what
the hell to do,
but I'm being
attacked constantly.
I've lost 50, or plus,
creator friends of mine.
And I also contacted my
friend, Sidney Watson,
who I think you know.
And she helped, she and Tim
helped me write the video.
And I posted the video,
and I just prayed to God.
Honestly, I didn't know what
to expect, I really didn't.
I was just tired of being
mentally and emotionally abused.
And I even made a video
about that, about how
all the tactics that the
progressive left uses these days
are emotionally, psychological
emotional abuse tactics.
The whole thing, like
trying to get you fired,
making sure that you only
talk to certain people,
like crazy shit that,
I've been in abusive
relationships before.
I started seeing the red flags.
I wasn't completely
convinced at first,
'cause I was like,
okay, just like,
they're just a bunch of kids.
But then my friends,
my ex-friends started
doing it to me.
And I was like, okay this is,
I have to put an end to this
and not allow myself to be
taken advantage of anymore.
- So I think the
million dollar question
that all gay people get asked,
when they come out as anything
other than progressive,
is, which was harder?
To come out of the closet,
or to come out as
a conservative,
or someone that is
just non-progressive?
- It was harder coming out
of the closet to myself.
It was harder coming out of the,
that's as a gay person.
It was harder coming
out of the closet
as a non-progressive
to the world. (laughs)
- I mean, it's
just extraordinary.
- Because it wasn't about,
yeah, because it was
about how they saw me,
not how I saw myself.
I always knew that
I was sort of,
at this point in my life,
I think I'm pretty much
fiscally conservative,
social libertarian,
socially libertarian,
like live and let live.
Don't touch me.
Let me do what I want
with my body, pretty much.
You know, don't take my
money, give me my guns.
Like I understand
guns rights now.
- Real, right-winged
extremist stuff.
- Yeah, of course,
like white nationalist
everything, you know.
That's where I'm at now.
And I think part of it also is
moving down to Florida part-time
made a big difference
in the way I thought,
because you know, New York
City is super progressive.
Florida's a little bit
more of a red state.
And I got that perspective
and it helped me, I guess,
centralize maybe, my
opinions on certain issues.
And I made, you know,
the best part of this all
is I made better
friends from it,
better friends
that, now when I get
online bullied or
harassed, whatever,
the people that, on the
left, never would help,
never, ever would
stick up for me.
All the people on the right,
all these terrible people
that everyone's
making it out to,
makin' out to seem like
they're terrible people,
all of them always
come to my defense,
every single time.
- I know the feeling.
- Yeah, and it's, it's just,
it's mind blowing to
me how opposite it is,
compared to what the
media portrays them to be.
- Has it been kind of
disappointing for you to see
what you described
with the gay community?
I was never really in the
gay community in that way.
I actually had a, I had a
gay radio show on Sirius XM,
so I guess I had a
year or two of my life
that I was sort
of in that world,
but I never really
felt like I was in it.
I was also closeted later and,
just the way my life
was, it's just how it is.
But to see now,
when people talk about
the gay community,
it seems like they've gone from
being edgy and controversial
and sort of subversive
and interesting,
and there was music and
fashion and blah, blah, blah,
to now it's like the worst
- Politics.
- sort of social-preening,
political hysterics, yeah.
- Like I have friends
of mine that went to,
you know, they go to
Florida Pride parades,
and they get, they get harassed,
like verbally, not, thank God,
I don't think anyone's
throwing anything at them.
But they get verbally harassed,
cursed at and, just for
being a conservative,
for believing in
something different.
He doesn't, you know, my friend,
David, Brokeback Patriot.
What's upsetting to me the most,
I think over the last two years,
is when I, and this is maybe
an ego thing a little bit,
I'm not gonna lie.
But it was also a comfort thing.
When I used to go out
to these Pride marches,
and lesbian events
or LGBT events like,
you know, Playlist
Live, VidCon, whatever,
kids used to come up to
me and cry, actually,
I'm not even kidding, like cry,
telling me that I
saved their life,
or I at least
changed their life.
I helped them come
out of the closet,
I helped them be who
they, be who they are.
And it's like, I'm the same
person that I was back then.
I just am more honest and
open with my opinions now.
Even though to me,
they're still pretty,
you know, mainstream,
mainstream opinions.
Now when I go to Pride parades,
and I go to safe spaces,
I'm not even kidding,
I don't feel safe anymore.
I went to a,
I went to a gay bar in Tampa,
and it could be just me
being in my own head,
I really don't know.
My friends saw it too though,
so maybe it wasn't
just me in my own head
there was an older trans woman
assumingly, a trans woman,
and I coulda sworn
she was staring at me.
And my first thought
of course, is,
not that she's thinking
about hitting on me.
My first thought is, oh my
God, this person knows who I am
and thinks I'm a transphobe,
and is gonna attack me.
And I don't wanna
think that way,
'cause that's assuming
somebody's something
that they might not be.
But it's gotten to that point.
People, like I said, people
used to come up to me, hug me.
Now people at Pride
parades and events
will come up to me in private,
and do one of these things.
Do they do that to you too?
Like, "I just want you to know,
like I can't say this out loud,
but I really, really
appreciate what you're doing."
And I'm like, Goddamn it!
You can't say it louder?
They, they won't do
it. They're terrified.
But most, you and I
know at this point,
most people agree with
what you and I say.
- That's what I think too,
because I don't think any,
nobody's happier
because of this thing.
You know, it sort of was like
when Pride Month rolled around,
or I used to go to the Pride
parade in New York City,
which is always the
last Sunday of June,
and my birthday's, my
birthday is June 26th.
So I actually met my husband,
who I've now been
with for 10 years,
on my birthday at Gay Pride.
- I love that.
- Believe it or not.
And he was wearing an
American flag tank top.
It was, it was all meant to be.
- I love it.
- But yeah, when I
would go there then,
people would sort of love me,
because I had this radio
show, and I was a lefty.
And I don't really
go to them anymore.
But I did go to the Abbey,
which is the big gay
bar of West Hollywood.
I went about a year ago.
And for the first time in my
life, I was kinda worried.
'Cause I was like I don't
know what these people
are gonna think about me,
exactly what you're saying.
But I will say,
not only did nobody
say anything negative to me,
but several people
did come up to me.
And I could tell they
were a little nervous,
like, oh, maybe I shouldn't
be seen with Dave.
But they were like,
Dave, I'm with you.
- Thank God.
- So they, they are waking up.
'Cause gays are supposed
to be individuals,
not group monolithic thinkers.
- Yes. That's the
whole point, isn't it?
We were born different, I think,
and this is like a
little spiritual lesson.
But I think when
you're born different,
it's a gift, right?
It's a gift to,
and being yourself because
you're different, is a gift,
because you allow other people
the chance to be themselves.
You show them that it's okay.
And I don't, I think
if we are a monolith,
I think that's the opposite
of what our path
is as LGBT people.
You know, we have the
opportunity to be leaders,
and we're being followers.
And I refuse that, you know.
- Are you hopeful that we
can turn this thing around?
It seems like so much
of the woke thing
is attached to the trans thing,
where every day there's
another trans story.
I even talk about it
with my guys on the show,
when we're figuring
out the rundown,
and I'm like, I don't
really feel like
doing another trans
story just because
we're overblowing this thing.
You know, I'm saying with you,
I don't care, I'll call you.
If you treat me with respect,
I'll treat you with respect.
I called Caitlyn Jenner.
She, I don't have any
problem with that.
But that the issues, these,
they've just bludgeoned
us with these issues
to the point that
I actually think
they're starting to
cause a backlash.
I actually think there's some
backlash on the gays now, too,
because of this,
- Huge!
- Because they feel like,
oh, see what happened?
The gays became equal, and
now look what happened.
Now boys have vaginas,
- Slippery slope,
- and girls have penises.
- it's a slippery
slope argument.
Right, no, and I
agree with them.
I agree with the people
that it is a slippery slope.
I think, which is
why I call myself,
in this sense, a
conservative, meaning to me,
what a conservative means these
days is a classic liberal.
And I think that's
how you identify,
correct me if I'm wrong.
- Yeah, although,
I don't have a problem saying
conservative at this point.
But yes, my beliefs...
- But New New Age conservatism
is classic, in my,
it's from looking
at all the people
who identify that way now.
So that's where
I've always been.
And the Democrats,
progressives, liberals,
whatever you wanna
call them on that side,
it's just the most
toxic behavior I've seen
from a group of
people in a long time.
I haven't even seen,
I've never met a
religious person
that was far right, that
treated me that way,
the way the people
on the left do.
- While they're telling
you how tolerant they are,
that's the beauty of it.
- Yeah. That's well, yeah,
that's just another
abusive tactic, right?
Gaslighting, like actual
gaslighting. (laughs)
Like, I'm being nice,
I care about you.
Like nah, it's like
no you (laughs),
clearly you don't.
You don't respect me at all.
I think that,
I think that we have
a long way to go,
because people are
so guilted right now
into virtue signaling
and trying to be
the most wokest, the
wokest, or the most woke.
And I think that's because
there's an extreme lack
of self-awareness
and self, self-worth
from these people
that are, that are
doing this kind of
virtue signaling, whatever
you wanna call it.
They need to be
confident in themselves,
especially the trans
community, in my opinion.
I'm gonna get shit
for saying that,
but you know, what
it is, what it is.
Anyone that, that's
very different
needs to get their act together,
be okay with being different
and become a leader,
and stop needing validation.
They have to stop needing
and wanting validation
from everyone else
from the entire world.
And I think once they do that,
and they show that, you know,
like Caitlyn Jenner,
I think is a really good
example, to be honest.
I think she is,
she holds a lot of respect
from a lot of people,
even if they don't agree
with her being tran.
Not that you can't
agree with being trans,
'cause you can't
fix it, help it.
But even if somebody
disagrees with her,
I think they have a
lot of respect for her,
because she speaks
logical, logically.
And I think that's
where the left
is completely messing up.
None of them are making
any sense at the moment.
None of them.
It's all based on,
no, it's all based
on identity politics,
and you know, people
wanting to be nice. (laughs)
- What do you, what do you say,
or what advice would you have
if there is a young
gay kid watching this,
a 15-year-old, that
sort of understands
that the woke thing is wrong?
Because we also know that now
the zoomers, the young
generation, after Generation Y,
they are leaning
more conservative,
because they've seen this
thing go so out of whack.
But what would you say
to a young gay kid,
young girl who's,
who wants to come out
but doesn't wanna be completely
just swarmed by that thing?
- It's tough because I've, I
get messages more like that
every day than people,
people assume I get
hit on all the time
in my direct messages.
It's not like that.
It's always these
types of messages.
Like what do I do?
I'm more conservative,
or I don't believe
in this crazy shit
that they're spewing.
I don't know how to speak up.
You have to figure it out.
You have to figure
out how to speak up,
as long as you're safe.
Because in my opinion,
I think, you know this.
If every single person that
agreed with us spoke up,
this would end tomorrow.
- [Dave] It would end tomorrow.
- It would end today.
It really would.
It really would,
because there are a lot
more of us than them.
That doesn't mean that we're,
we're correct on the issue
just 'cause there's more of us.
But in this case, I
do think, you know,
it's just a bonus that there
happens to me more of us,
and we also happen to be on
the right side of history,
so to speak. pun
intended, I guess.
(Dave laughs)
My advice would be,
you're born to, to be different.
And this is just
another chance to be,
to be different
and be proud of it,
to think differently.
Everyone's scared these
days to think differently.
And if you can do that,
and prove that that's okay,
and know that that's
okay to yourself
and show others
that that's okay,
you're gonna be the
start of something,
it's gonna be the start
of something big for them.
- Have you gotten any real
hate from people on the right?
'Cause I think for me, what,
one of the things that was
kind of surprising was,
that really didn't happen.
Yes, there's this
very tiny sliver
of anonymous weirdos on Twitter,
who seem to be on the
right and hate gays.
But in reality, whether I was
sitting down with Ben Shapiro,
who has a different
religious perspective
on gay marriage, let's say,
or scary Glenn Beck,
or any of these people,
I found nothing but support.
I found nothing but
humanity and decency.
I go to evangelical events
and get standing ovations.
I just find tolerance there.
Even though perhaps
they have a different,
some of them have perhaps a
different religious belief.
- Yeah, people are
gonna think I'm lying,
I'm grifting for this,
but I really haven't had
any bad experiences yet.
Even when I, like you said,
you disagree with them,
they're like, okay,
I don't agree,
but I still love you.
I still respect you as a person.
Okay. Like I'm pro-choice.
I'm always gonna be pro-choice,
'cause I'm a
traditional feminist,
not these crazy third and
fourth-wave feminists.
Oh my God.
But yeah, I think...
Yeah, no, I don't, I think
it's much better on
this side overall.
I haven't really had any, any,
like even I met up with Ben
Shapiro, Ben Shapiro in LA,
and he said the most Ben
Shapiro thing to me ever,
(both laughing)
in his little, you
know how he talks?
- Dude, give me a Ben
Shapiro impression, come on.
- I'm gonna try,
but he was like,
you know, you know
what the conservatives
haven't cared about gays
since like 1990, right?
Like (laughs)
really, so quickly,
and he shook his head,
and he did one of
those things, like,
you know, we don't
care anymore, right?
And I was like, I was
like, well now I know.
I didn't know before,
but he's like,
yeah, we, nobody cares, nobody.
- I don't know if you know
my story of meeting Trump.
But I met Trump in 2019,
right before Christmas.
And when he realized
that I was gay,
I was standing with
David, and he got up,
he slapped his
hands on the table.
He goes, "I just want you to
know, I don't give a shit,
and I don't think anyone
else gives a shit,
and I don't think they've
given a shit for 20 years."
And I was like, oh.
- I think that's accurate.
- This is the homophobe.
This is the Homophobe-in-Chief.
- Yeah. Yeah, I don't,
I don't think, like I...
He's a New Yorker, and I
don't know any New Yorker
that gives a shit
about who's gay.
None of them, none
of them give a shit.
In fact, they'll probably like
you more because you're gay,
because you're like, you
offer some new perspective,
and that's very New York.
You know how you 'cause
you're a New Yorker.
That's a very New
York thing. Yeah.
- Are you, are you hopeful
that we'll get
through this thing?
I mean, I'm with you that
if everyone just spoke up,
that's the only way to stop it.
There's no, there's no
magic white knight coming.
But are you hopeful that
people will actually do it?
- I'm always gonna
be hopeful because...
But you know what?
If I'm, if, if I'm wrong,
that's just more job
security for us, right?
We just can keep making...
(both laughing)
- I say it all the time,
and I honestly mean it.
I would much rather
things get fixed,
and I'll find something
else to do if I have to.
I really, I really do mean that.
- I can go back to talking
about lesbian sex, you know.
That's just as
good in my opinion.
Instead of, instead of
doing damage control-
- I'm not gonna
ask you about that.
I'm very confused about
the whole thing, frankly.
- (laughs) Okay.
- But I think it's great that
you're doing it, you know?
- There's so much to talk about,
like so much.
Guys, it's so simple.
- You're also on local, so I
wanna, I wanna pimp that out.
Because you decided that you
can't be beholden to the,
to the big tech machine.
'Cause you've, you've had
some stuff censored, right?
- Oh yeah.
I've been demonetized,
I think three times
for a month at a time,
over the last two years.
- Like your entire channel,
not just just random videos.
- The entire channel.
- Your whole catalog.
- Yup. And I've been making
the same content for 10 years.
So all of a sudden I come out
as more conservative leaning,
and then they demonetize me?
It's a little fishy if
you ask me, so yeah.
(Dave hums)
Yeah, somethin's up.
- Is it just arielle.locals.com?
- Yep, yep.
- Arielle.locals.com. We'll
link to it right down below.
Well, listen.
- Thank you so much, David.
- Have a, have a very
prideful Pride Month.
We get a whole month.
Isn't that exciting?
- That's a long, yeah,
that's the long-ass time.
I'm gonna be walkin' around
with a MAGA hat possibly,
or some kind of, I
don't know, somethin',
and going into safe spaces.
Maybe I'm gonna film
some stuff, I don't know.
- Well, good luck with that.
- At this point,
(laughs) Yeah, thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about women's issues
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our Women's
Issues playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our Full Episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.